started last talk of a workshop XJ Wang
and why you saw this is the last talk so
I propose that the way a round of
applause to the organizers this is very
exciting stimulating workshop and thank
you for inviting me so I thought I would
like to share with you in this talk some
of our work ongoing work of the last few
years trying to go beyond the local
circuit and think about how we can start
build a large-scale multi-regional
cortical circuit model so some of you
may know that for many years research in
my lab has been focused on some cortical
areas that has especially important for
cognitive computation as say in contrast
to early sensory coding and processing
so we have been focusing on this
particular area called prefrontal cortex
indicated by blue across six different
species which is believed to be really
important for many different kinds of
cognitive processes but our Sun is still
very limited in fact as indicated by
this graph which is the number of papers
published every five years ways that he
know a key word prefrontal cortex you
see that you know the interest and the
research has going up only in last few
decades so it's really recent that
neuroscientists three deists started to
devote serious efforts to understand
prefrontal cortex so over the years many
people of course experimentally and
in combination in neuroscience trying to
ask how we can really look at the
cognitive functions and different people
tend to focus on particular cognitive
process indicated here by you know given
example names some physiologists working
as a monkey
I feel working with rodents in these
days say dedicating their efforts to say
study simple decision-making to working
memory or to selective attention
valuation inhibitor control of action
you know maybe have been more abstract
representation of behavior Rubik cetera
and in parallel because we also try to
develop some computational modeling to
understand you know each of those what
we call building blocks of cognition but
at some point I guess as a field you
know we have this increasing awareness
that each of these processes engages
more than one brain region right so if
you talk about the working memory in the
delayed task the representation of
working memory seem to involve many
different brain areas cortical
subcortical and of course in daily life
any flexible behavior depends on
multiple of those building blocks and
again each one engages a subnetwork of
the brain system so we really I think as
a field should start to think about how
really we can confront this challenge
and start to think about the bigger
system going beyond the local circuit ok
so this is the motivation for the kind
of research that who have been carrying
out over the last few years that's the
question so we decided to start with a
recently published database about
cortical to cortical connectivity
Kotex this is a recently published work
from Helen Kennedy School where they
used rather traditional vertical trace a
technique but very quantitatively there
has certain way to quantify the
connection strength from one area to
another C and up with a connectivity
matrix that's directed and waited
okay so among the main observation that
you know whatever way they come up was
to measure the strength of connection
that weights those you know the values
of that weight between areas spend five
orders of magnitude and can be fed with
with normal distribution and the the
weight of connection between two areas
is a exponentially decaying function of
the distance between the two areas so
that's the way they quantify the
connection weight which has to do with
the fraction of neurons that are labeled
that project to a given target area for
multiple source areas so it's a relative
measure of you know improve weights to a
given target area anyway so we decided
to use this database to constrain the
structure connectivity in our dynamical
large-scale brain circuit model so we
started with the South graph for which
we have this connectivity data with
multiple visual areas some prefrontal
areas and you know the experiment is
being ongoing so we continue to have
newer more and more data for four
additional areas in the model now the
buter dynamical model of course the next
question to ask is what would you do
with well building dynamics in each
local circuit so our approach is to
assume a very simple so it depend on the
questions of course that you want to
investigate you choose
the right at an angle model right and to
start with who used a very simple
stretch Oh Nene
EW network for each cortical area and
that's actually coming from the
literature from modern Douglass group
and the model was kind of collaborated
by the physiology of v1 in a macaque
cortex so the ideas that would use the
same kind of local circuit model for the
first rung of a simulation for each of
the cortical areas in the large-scale
model in the spirit of assuming there's
a kind of canonical local circuit
however will Sassoon that there are some
quantitative changes from area to area
which would correspond to certain
parameters in this equation that would
be different from area to area so for
that we look at a very interesting
separate database about spine count that
I'm going to show in the next slide
which seemed to vary systematically
along the cortical hierarchy so this is
an example from Elston showing the
number of spines per neuron which is
different from area to area okay if you
plot the number of spots per neurons in
this particular example will be the most
finds in the in the basal enjoyed of
layer 2 3 p.m. the cell you see a
systematically increase of that as
function of the hierarchical position of
the cortical area right we would take
this as a proxy about as a you know a
proxy of the number of excitatory inputs
proneural that changes from area to area
and that we would incorporate that into
the model which would be this parameter
rh i i've been the index for the area
and that will increase systematically
along hierarchy right the rather simple
model but with some anatomical
constraint about the area to area
connectivity and this gradient of the
amount of excitation per neuron if you
like across
this this whole system so this is a
simulation of the model where you
provide a input to v1 and watch the
response from each of the cortical areas
in the model and by the way this is the
model really at the core of the PhD
series by ratio is here in the audience
who is Rishi is the very brave and the
risk-taking graduate student in a lab
who really a spare how did this there's
a construction of the model anyway so
what do you see is that different areas
here you know codified in color that the
time course of response changed quite a
bit from area to area right another way
to quantify you know the time course of
response to given external stimulus is
the exactly same equations yes same taos
except again the amount of excitation is
scaled by that that gradient Falls for
the local excitation and long-distance
excitation so this is another way to
look at the time scale of dynamics in
each local circuit here we drove receipt
of the system by providing a noisy input
to v1 okay and you kind of see that the
fluctuation has different time scales in
different areas right of course you can
quantify that I look at autocorrelation
function of the time series from each
area again each one is given here in
different color and you can fit that
autocorrelation function with say a
exponential decaying function or a sum
of two Exponential's and you can you
know extract a weighted time constant
that way then you find that indeed
there's a broad range of time constants
like early century areas such as v1 has
a time
about 20 milliseconds consistent with
the observations by people like Massimo
Gianni where some other areas have time
constants you know all the way up to a
couple of seconds in this example the
x-axis is the hierarchical position of
cortical areas right so I want to make a
couple comments here number one the in a
way this hierarchy of time constants is
really functionally very desirable right
you want early signs of areas to operate
very fast where's some higher areas may
be involved in time integration of the
information during decision-making
process your putti are familiar with
drifted division model as a very simple
model for accumulation of information in
decision-making and that assumes that
the defective time constant of the
system is very long right so when you
see here that that you know a range of
time constants to somehow emerge emerges
from the system yeah no so that's a very
important point to say it explicitly I
did not say that explicitly so the
connectivity between areas is given by
the measured mesoscopic connectivity
matrix from Harry Kennedy there's a lot
of recurrent connections among all
possible connections about 65% of
connections exist so it's a pretty dense
graph or a sub graph if you like but
again the ways of connections are very
heterogeneous right spending 500
magnitude question so this
autocorrelation is computed from giving
input to be 1 or giving input to the
area in question you want just noise
inputs yeah in fact it's
it's a cumulative effect of all the well
it is but that does not explain what do
you see I guess but it's legit made a
question right so you can have this
that's a integration of the equation of
integration
right that could give you a sore more
sluggish response that well we actually
had did the model 2 to see how much
right that effect can come for the
observed you know dynamics it's not
enough for sure but the other things
that would you like to think about this
is more about the decay time constant
rather than the latency of response of
lessons your onset response it's more
likely how slow the response of decay
away when the input it goes away
maybe it's also was mentioning that that
the time constant is not a monotonic
function of the hierarchical position
right and that in part is because of
this complicated feedback connection
loops so for example area 8 which is
from high field it's actually really low
in the hierarchy light purple here but
it has pretty long time constant because
it's really part of the frontal lobe it
interacts quite a bit with the other
peripheral areas higher in the hierarchy
if you randomly scramble the long
distance connection weights while
preserving exactly the same set of
weights this is pretty much gone ok so I
know this is a in a way it's really a
mathematical or computational workshop
so I would like to emphasize that this
is a very interesting mathematical
program that we we're pursuing to
understand better what's shown here
think about this is you think about this
is a purely linear system right
selection linear that say o above
threshold you have really an inner
system then the time constants are just
given by the real part of the eigen
values right of the system so for each
item mode you can also compute
in vector right so the this hierarchy of
time Carson should be understood in
terms of how much you know each of the
egg mode working vector involves a small
part of the part of the system and
whether the small part of a big part of
the system especially together or not
right so that's quantified here by those
two numbers so basically the x-axis so
each each star is egg mode the color
corresponds to the time constant here so
blue is short orange or red is long for
each other mode you can ask what's the
fraction of the nodes or areas are
involved right namely the eigenvector is
not another components of a vector are
not a negligible for certain areas okay
so if you go this way you have more
localization let me you have less
fraction of areas engaging in that for
that particular for that particular mode
where's along the y axis that is a
measure of how spatially together are
the engaged notes right so the higher
you go the more specially localized
those nodes are there together rather
than schedule right so you see actually
so those are you know a few examples
especially if you look at this
particular wire and that particular one
right they have the same fraction of
note small s right there are involved in
each of the two but the value along
y-axis are quite different then you seek
here clearly here right for this one the
notes that are involved together
especially with those ones are more
scattered in space all right and look at
this one this is pretty amazing you have
eigenmode right that's really realized
and it was a pretty long time constant
right
how can you have a sole mode that's
especially so localized anyway
more generally right if you you think
this connectivity matrix from hurricane
et
is an interesting one for macaca codex
you can ask what's the class of brain
circuits and dynamics that give a rise
to this hierarchy of tying houses I
think that's a very general mathematical
question
lovey and Cosmo Bordeaux showed in the
mouse that the frontal area a LM when
you when you silence the thalamic input
it decays in ten milliseconds the
activity decays and generally can that
be accommodated okay so there are
several things about cars followed us
finding so why of course is that you
know this is data based McCarrick
connectivity data that you know pizza
macaque connecting to analysis and it's
not mice also its own accord x in in
Karl's experiment that's a delay task
and they found that the proprietary
activity during the delay period is
actually I would say not about
representation of sensory working memory
it's about preparation for the motor
response and that activity depends on
thermal core galoop so if you inactivate
a thalamus that activity essentially is
gone rather quickly it's not directly
related all the other
so you see one day a young inactivated
thalamus the activity in a LM
essentially disappears
what that means to me is that you know
those area if that's true right neurons
in those hair in that area in a sense
you don't get a lot of your current
cortical inputs right it's the if
neurons are were independent from each
other which seem a bit hard to explain
right even we know about the
connectivity in the cortex the other
thing I was about to mention is that
this is a if you like still anemia
analysis what we are doing now is to
look at a fully known in your version of
the network model to look at distributed
persons activity and I think that's a
better framework to really compare who
is with those kind of experiments and of
course we also have plans to build a
similar kind of using similar kind of
approach to build a model for mouse
system no there's any reality to these
groupings that you're showing here or
these these collections of notes I mean
is there any way to kind of validate
that the model isn't just spitting out
kind of random black dots I mean how do
you have you looked at these areas and
tried to look for evidence that these
areas are activated together in some
task or how do we how should we view
this yeah so we spend sometimes think
about this if the one idea would be this
is a modeling finding right but again I
think in general this is a race a set of
interesting theoretical questions about
hierarchy of time constants and
localization of eigenmodes
in rather thing interests in circuit
because it's based on real connectivity
matrix but he asked how they test this
experimentally
I guess one way to think about testing
this is to look at resting state
measurements was really big you know
high temporal resolution right I was
about to show a slide actually this is a
slide about you know one way whatever
way you measure functional connectivity
which is really a measure of correlation
between activities between pairs of
areas in a resting state and then we
some have some predictions about the you
know signature right of this kind of
hierarchy of time constants that you
could observe in function collective
matrix so let me go on if I can to tell
you a few other things I'd be happy to
come back to some of this at the end of
the talk so
well since maybe some of you noticed and
some have not is that in this let me go
back in this plot there's a huge
attenuation of signal right so the fine
right here is about 100 Hertz by the
time you get to the prefrontal cortex
there's this interesting slow after
discharges but the amplitude of response
is ridiculous it is small right so
essentially a signal attenuates when
this when it tries to propagate across
the system and that is a well-known
problem in computational science and so
that's under the name of well signal
propagation problem you've probably
heard about this classic work and and
many people have worked on this but so
far this kind of you know studies
computational studies of signal
propagation usually use rather simple
architecture typically the connectivity
is purely fit for all each layer is
identical he is some kind of random
connection with the same weights right
and typically people found that either
the signal does die out or you know the
system may become unstable right under
some conditions like shown here
by these men and others you could have
rather robust propagation now we thought
we should revisit this issue because now
we have this kind of more realistic
connectivity matrix with a lot of
feedback projections with a lot of
heterogeneity in connection weights it's
important to see whether we can deal
with this signal propagation problem in
this more realistic mckarrick oracle
large-scale system so feedbacks
sometimes really cause for headache as
can meter also kind of indicated and
shown here so suppose that in you you
drive v1 here and watch the response in
both of you are and the higher area like
prequel codex in this case a CC so
either you get a huge attenuation so
this is long you know along the y-axis
about the fine right
you see p1 has a decent response over
time but again when you're a cop of the
hierarchy the signal is basically gone
now you can try to scale the absolute
connection strength a little bit to try
to boost the signal propagation but then
you'd end up with this kind of
instability basically because of the
feedback loops right so now the ACC
signal increases which through feedbacks
through you know complicated pathways v1
actually can come back so to speak so
there's all this big feedback you know
excitation and basically the system
becomes unstable right and so we were
really inspired by commuters work on
local circuits so they came up with this
idea of so-called balanced amplification
essentially you can increase excitation
to induce this transient boost of
response but also increase feedback
inhibition to ensure stability of the
network so we we try that and this is
the control case with attenuation right
very small response median of the
hierarchy but when we generalized that
idea to this multi regional system from
area to area so you enhance excitation
from one area to another but also
enhance local inhibition to
counterbalance and ensure stability now
the signal is much better by
a hundredfold a perhaps better show here
so this is a the the response amplitude
for different areas along hierarchy
without this balanced amplification in
green and purple is the case when we
used can winners trick so to speak for
this logical system we also tested the
signal propagation with spiking your own
version of the Malo so this is the first
time we actually have thousands of
spiking neurons for each area in this
large scale system and look at the
signal propagation we found synchronized
bursts that propagates
we also found another regime
asynchronous you know activity that
propagates across areas and of course
people have found both regimes
previously to in a simpler feed-forward
Network one thing that's kind of
interesting is that we noticed that this
signal is faster and and you know more
robust across the ventral pathway and we
went back to the connectivity you know
histogram from the experimental
measurements and found that the
connection weights along the venture
pathway tend to be stronger compared to
the overall our connection weight is to
burn so this is just confirming that the
enhanced or ballast amplification
mechanism still works with spiking your
network now let me mention one more
thing that that's a bit surprising to me
there was this idea of so-called
ignition phenomena promoted by people
like standard Han as a signature of you
know a awareness conscious report so
basically the idea is that if you say
use a near threshold stimulus sometimes
you perceive it sometimes you don't you
know
they have some evidence using EEG kind
of measurements that when you don't
perceive it the activities seem to be
mostly confined in the posterior area
but when you report that you have
detected a near actual stimulus there's
this kind of global ignition type of the
phenomenon we found that in fact
different types of areas in our model
respond to stimuli of different
strengths differently in particularly
higher areas like prefrontal sub regions
in red seem to have this threshold
effect okay so if you're below the
threshold the activity is confined in
posterior area but evey above you have
this kind of global distributed activity
pattern and that in fact this
non-linearity the stretch would be in
fact disappears when you took away the
feedback connections you know we have
like three minutes let me just briefly
mention two other things maybe three
other things it's just - I think
highlight kind of new questions I think
we can start to investigate I think it's
formulate and investigate in this kind
of large scale model so one of the
things is about the interactions between
bottom-up and and top-down right so if
you're interested in Perdita coding how
the kind of predictive signal from from
feedback projections would interact with
the reality through the feed-forward
signaling well to start to you know
build a platform to adjust that question
we decided incorporate layers okay
because the feed fold and feedback
projections are layer dependent so we
have to skip some details in inches of
time we kind of build this next
generation of the model based on
some information about a cross layer and
lay dependent connectivity and we also
incorporated a bit more interesting
dynamics in this in this model so now we
have a superficial layer and the deep
layer in in each local circuit and the
superficial layer has stochastic tamped
gamma oscillations whereas the player
has slower the low beta or alpha
fluctuations and so we connected them
and just to sorry for the rush we try to
use our model to reproduce some monkey
physiological reservations to validate
our models and reconstruct
physiologically hierarchy using this
approach and so so this is the monkey
data results and this is our model
additional finding which you know but
the two are consistent with each other
just to say that you know we now I think
in a position to start to ask real
serious computational questions with
this platform however the meander was
one more puzzle and one you know idea
about maybe addressing this puzzle
namely you know as I was mentioning the
connectivity is very dance each year we
are cat simple for maybe thirty other
areas right there's this really urge and
need to think about a gating mechanism
that routing information to the right
place to the right time right there's no
way for such a system to work if we
don't have such a making gating
mechanism so we exploited this kissing
in between motif you know mechanism for
getting I don't want to skip this let me
take a half minute to explain this I
think it's very very
promising to look at this important
problem so as you know there's a
diversity of inhibitory neurons and
roughly speaking there are three major
types let's say the first type in back
in black target the soma or initial
segment of Aksum of pyramidal cells and
that's well-positioned to control the
spiking output of preeminent cells
there's a second type in blue that
controls the input flow to dandrites or
PM the cells with a third type in green
prefers early target blue cells right so
depending on whether the blue cells are
very active in which case you would
block the input to the land rights or
the green cells are activated then they
can suppress blue cells and let a gate
open so to speak right and each of the
three has distinct chemical marker and
this one for example express PV was this
one may express motor statin or any
there's a very strong evidence for this
theoretical we proposed a motif in
recent experimental studies using
genetic tools so I'm going to skip the
details of how we incorporated this
teasing with motive for gating and that
paper is is published if you're
interested but I want to mention that
actually the input control in some other
state in the neurons and out of the
control in PB in the neurons do not have
the same proportions from area to area
so what's shown here is the paper they
just came out where they counted the
different kinds of coverage cells
throughout the whole mouse brain all
right what's shown here in black is the
ratio as pv develop a pv x clusters some
of student neuron count four different
cortical areas in mice
you know monotonically okay
this is the highest the lowest ratio
over here you have more penis PV cells
than SS T cells namely in those areas
there are more optical journey into
neurons than input the conjoining in the
neurons whereas over here you know you
have almost a 4 times input the
conjoining in the neurons that Express
the motor state and then out output
controlling interneurons what's
interesting in addition is that when you
just arranged areas by this number early
sensory areas although market fall off
here where higher areas like the pre
lumping areas you know association areas
at the bottom namely that high areas you
know have a lot more important control
in coverage excels which may be
functionally very interesting if you
think about gating so let me end with
this slide suggesting that you know one
way to start to think about this
complicated large-scale brain system
right what does it mean to build a
large-scale system can we expect to find
any kind of general principle given the
complexity in the messiness of
everything that we just heard well one
one way we're pursuing at least is this
idea of macroscopic of gradient right so
you have some canonical organization
that may apply to each of the local
circuits at the same time certain
circuit properties such as spine current
proneural such as you know input
controlling versus output controlling
inhibiting neurons may systematically
change along certain axis in the
cortical circuit and if you are from
nonlinear dynamical systems world you
know that some quantitative changes can
give a rise to qualitatively
very different behavior right is through
what's called bifurcation in
so we are pursuing this idea that you
know you know maybe stay here in the
next slide right how to reconcile on one
hand it's a unitary eye view of codex
and modularity of different cognitive
functions is you know exploring this
idea that qualitative changes can give
rise to qualitative different functions
of course plus plasticity let me end by
thanking people who did the work so how
you define to her was it was at least
under layers like speak connections of
so you macaque hierarchies define the
exactly based on a layer dependence of
projections in mice I guess some people
have tried but so far we don't know of a
clear well-defined hierarchy right you
know the product showed you actually is
not based on defined hierarchy actually
we just arranged in areas by this number
and just somehow early sensory areas we
know I think it's right primary sensory
areas we know who they are tend not to
be around here whereas Association areas
like pre-olympic you know in for Olympic
areas tend out to be at the bottom we
don't know what actually is the best way
to define hierarchy for the macaque
that's indeed based on physiology it's a
good question whether you could think
about using similar can approach to two
mice in fact the same group who did the
monkey experiment attempted the same
thing with human so they used a migi
data and because that particular
analysis was based on physiological data
whether anatomic data so they actually
apply that approach to I mean G data and
claim they could find a pretty you know
well-defined hierarchy in human and of
course for human cortex we also don't
have anatomically define the hierarchy
so maybe somebody could try that in with
Mouse
control decision and so that you did not
as I recall include language idea in
that early slide mentioning yeah on
faculty psychology from modularity of
mind making the point that faculty
psychologies for example expressed
language that's cold this note you know
here here about decision motor and so on
its own language
what do you call anguish yeah building
blocks of cognition so I guess we used
the term building blocks basic building
blocks of cognition
those are kind of relatively simple
elementary processes
you know let's say how do you make a
simple decision how do you hold some
information in your mind in absence of
external stimulus how do you suppress
you know prepotent automatic response to
KO the inhibitor control so those are
kind of really simple you know elements
of cognition that people can study
rather well with single neurophysiology
in behaving animals so those are the
wise things we tend to focus on so we
can try to relate our model with with
the physiology and behavior language
definitely of course is very important
for human intelligence but it's probably
at the next level we we we put you have
to think about more elementary more
fundamental processes such as sequence
such as grammar right but you know i
think it's useful to think this way
right so for example the the hierarchy
of time Carlsen's 10 that we well
received by people who work with human
because there's this person Yuri Hansen
at Princeton he studies speech
comprehension right so you you
understand words
with very short time scale right a ver
time show us your skill and then you
integrate words into a phrase from
phrases to sentences from services
learner and narrative and he showed that
actually this kind of time integration
of different skills involve different
you know segments of the cortex so
there's this idea of hierarchy of time
constants that allow you to do that
right but we're not there we don't work
on language yeah yeah about the ignition
phenomena that stem the hand can you
show the slide again and so in the hands
case well you know what is the analogy
in your case for enough for the stimuli
that can be so so yeah it's the spot are
so the analogy would be that you put a
input right at searched here and your
dynamics is stochastic right so in some
trials a you know in some individual
trials the
the activity will be confined in the in
the posterior part of the cortex whereas
in some other fraction of Charles you'll
get this more global activity pattern
right one of the axis of the of this
graph the x axis this is the input
intensity so that I can change the
contrast of a stimulus right so you just
adjust the contrast to be a stimulus
right at the threshold of detection
[Applause]